[Music]
hey what's up my name's Samuel lives
the reason I'm wearing this is because
I'm here at Sai I've just bought a piece
of land and on this video I wanted to
talk to you about how to build houses
from scratch what you need to look for
how you do it so I mean to be honest
I've got like over a decade of
experience in buy-to-let development
it's still something that I'm still
learning as we go which is really
exciting so instead of buying a house
this time I decided to buy a piece of
land so this is not owned by me these
are apartments what is owned by me is
all this land here and what we're going
to do is build six houses absolutely
from scratch I'm going to document the
whole thing you're going to see how it
works I'm going to teach you guys along
the way we're gonna build a house here
we've already got the foundations being
set I mean there have been a few tiny
issues berry Mont I only complete it on
this land like two weeks ago and we've
got builders next week starting on the
putting all the timber frames that ready
to start building the houses this whole
thing this whole process should be done
between six and nine months everyone I'm
used to working on the castle we're
restoring your castle at the moment
grade 2 listed greatest our nightmare
taking forever this it's gonna be so
fast so what would eat what do we look
for when we when we got this piece of
land well for a start it's flat when
it's flat again it's a lot easier than
when it's on a hill secondly if you're
going to buy a piece of land to build on
it either make sure that you already
have planning permission to build or you
buy it subject to planning permission
because the last thing you want to do is
buy a piece of land I mean I bought this
for this was two no three hundred three
hundred and thirty thousand pounds
I bought this land for that last thing
you want to do spend three hundred and
thirty grand on a piece of land that
then you can't do anything with so we've
got planning permission or a day all
through to build six houses on it so
it's gonna be a house right here there's
going to be a house here and there's
going to be a third house here these
houses although they're terraced houses
and they're not going to be that big I
mean you know tear it three terraced
houses but here where we are we're in
st. Anne's in Lincoln
which they are some people call this
Millionaire's Row this is where the
wealthy people this is the affluent path
link of Lincoln so the houses should
sell for a reasonable profit once we've
got these three sorted there's going to
be three more houses at the back
foundations all good the parking here at
the back is going to be over there so
we're gonna flatten up want this curb
people come in park their three houses
three houses little front gardens
leaving a little patio to the back and
hopefully they should sell really
quickly see this curb here this whole
bird right now this is going to be
dropped which means that the cars will
be able to just move drive which is in
this area is such a big deal because
parking is a nightmare here it's gonna
add some serious value just by dropping
the curb now for me this project is not
a no money down deer I'm putting some
serious cash into this I'm spending
three hundred thirty thousand pounds
just to buy the land then it's going to
cost half a million to build the six
houses so all-in he's talking about
about eight hundred and thirty thousand
pounds that's including everything the
contingency and the whole works so this
is not a no-money-down deal for me
however ultimately it will be because
the money that I put in I'll be able to
pull back out plus way more it is a no
money down deal for my for my joint
venture partner on this so I'm doing
this with Trevor who's a who's a good
friend of mine and in fact Trevor's you
wanna just come on up Trevor this guy
lives how how far is your house on this
side about nine miles nine mile so it
takes you what like 15 minutes yeah 15
minutes so he lives 15 minutes away and
you know the area I do
links with all the builders and
contractors keep an eye on it so we set
up a joint venture on this how much
money are you putting into this deal
nothing nothing I'm putting the money in
how much profit are you hoping to make
from this deal within the within the
nine months period about half a million
pounds you're gonna half a million for
us how much would you make so hundred
ninety thousand pounds in about six to
twelve months putting in no money
absolute you're not even doing the work
now you're just overseeing the work so
it's not a bad pretty penny
to make considering you're not putting
any money at all my point of view I'm
going to make how much well I'm at like
about three hundred thousand twenty I
like about three hundred twenty thousand
I'm putting the money in but I'm not
putting any time in the only reason I'm
here today is just to have a meal with
Trevor to shoot a video like I don't
need to be here right now so for me this
is about as hands-off and passive as it
gets so that's not the perfect joint
venture it is when you get almost a
hundred percent return on your money
exactly in less than twelve months it's
not bad no and here's the thing the
thing is people that say you cannot do
no money down deals
I'm helping facilitate people do no
money down deals yeah you know so and
sometimes I do no money down deals
sometimes I put money down just depends
sometimes you put money down absolutely
sometimes you don't so you just got to
be creative but it's the perfect joint
venture so I'm super excited listen let
me give you guys two pieces of things
that you need to look for before buying
before buying development property I
talked a lot about buy-to-let
it's all about what you put down what
you get back your return on investment
we've developers there's basically three
things you need to look for number one
is what's the what's the purchase price
of what you're buying so in this case
the purchase price of this piece of land
was three hundred and thirty thousand
pounds that's the figure one figure two
is what's the refurb or development cost
so in this case that's going to be half
a million pounds to build six houses
that's going to be a maximum of five
hundred thousand pounds once you've got
those two figures the third figure is
just what's the end value so how much is
it going to be worth in total once it's
done when you've got these three figures
you can easily work out if it's a good
deal or not because if the third figure
is worth a lot more than these two you
put together you've got a good deal
these two put together is eight hundred
and thirty thousand pounds and value
what's the end value all right so
there's both that's why there's five
hundred thousand pound half a million
profit in the deal so that's how you
know if it's a good deal and I'm looking
forward to doing a lot more deals like
this I'm going to vlog this I'm going to
document the whole thing we've got a
time-lapse camera so you guys will get
to see the house being built up right
from scratch and see what it looks like
I'll be popping by every couple few
months dinner love day so I hope those
helpful it
was common below coming what your learns
can't what you like best and comment
what you want to see smash that like
button and subscribe I look forward to
seeing you next time
[Music]
you